speaking of arseholes online and people
are acting like arseholes online
yeah i'm scared yeah go go go back to
the uh
cycling special yeah so we've i mean
we've it's funny
how we've talked about like
online privacy so so much on this
podcast
yeah we've talked about it a lot and
sometimes i feel like we're you know
beating a dead horse because we're just
like yeah you know we have a lot of
crazy stories
yeah um so it it kind of surprises me
when there are still some people out
there
despite how many times we've talked
about it we'll do some uh
not pretty pretty not cool stuff yeah i
mean uh so if if you haven't been
following my twitter
so yeah someone someone tried to leak
some
monk photos that i had which were
private
on my mum's facebook and yeah uh i mean
i i said this
i said this on my twitter longer but you
know i i purposely didn't release it
because you know it's
i'm fine people knowing that i was a
monk and memeing that aspect just you
know
meaning the knowledge or whatever but i
was just like i kept
that part private because you know there
are like quite intimate photos it's like
a
religious ceremony so i didn't i didn't
want that part of my life there i mean
because when you initially told the
story i remember after it you were like
yeah boys i don't want to show a photo
i'm pretty sure he said it on the clip
did you like i'm pretty sure on the clip
we were like i think one of us said like
oh we'll put the pictures and then god
was like no i don't want to put the
pictures
oh yeah i think i might have said that
right it's been a while it's been a
while
yeah i
but uh yeah someone someone literally
stalked my mum's facebook
um which you know it's there's there's
there's a difference between you know if
i [ __ ] up and you know i
there's some part of my private life
that you know i forgot to private you
know it's still an [ __ ] move but you
know as a public figure you can expect
that people are going to try and dig
into your past everything like that
and of itself yeah yeah i mean it's uh
you know we can talk about that's
[ __ ] that you know we kind of had to
expect that but you kind of do have to
expect that but
it just felt dirty that someone tried to
stalk my family
especially like my close family yeah
that's actually [ __ ] yeah it's pretty
funny and like
these are really old pictures as well so
they would have had to go back
years and years worth of like my mom's
pictures that she's
creepy to think someone's just scrolling
i i don't know and and like all this all
this for a meme
it's like it's like that thanos mean
like all this for like a single meme
yeah
as well the person knew that they were
being scummy as well yeah they even like
self-admitted that they were like
yeah i know this is scummy lol it's like
no
because i feel like you know we i mean
we literally talked about this last week
where you know the
the barrier of privacy between reality
and what's entertainment is like slowly
slowly
drifting apart and slowly being erased
and
i don't know it feels weird finally
experiencing that for myself
and being in the crossfire yeah it sucks
i mean i i had to like tell my parents i
was like
you know because luckily my parents you
know they're mega boomers
so they they think that facebook is the
plague and always has been yeah so they
never signed up to it
yeah um but i still have to tell them
like listen if anyone asks you questions
about me
or like anything private about me or
tries to get anything just tell them
like
okay don't answer it just tell them to
ask me like if
if even if it's like you know like
someone claiming to be like a government
agency which like i think
somebody i remember who called them up
and asked
somehow got my parents number or
something and we're like trying to ask
them questions about me
like don't don't answer anything just
you know if the police want me
the police will find me right i mean
like yeah
anyone who claims to be anything don't
[ __ ] tell them anything
it's sad that you have to do that right
yeah like the thought i think it's just
really sad
that i would rather be harassed like a
hundred times personally yeah that my
parents be harassed once
yeah yeah i mean like i just couldn't
because they've got nothing to do with
it why didn't i
get involved right it's hard enough
raising me as it was right like let
alone
the little [ __ ] that you are the little
[ __ ] that i was you know it's hard
enough
i don't want to have to give them extra
work after yeah they're trying to enjoy
retirement you know so
it's it's it's been kind of funny seeing
the transition between
like my parents at least because my
parents like really technologically
illiterate
and i've had to basically teach them
everything but it's been funny seeing
the transition between
them like not understanding social media
at all and just like
not using it at all and then
transitioning that to
like transitioning that to most of my
family now use facebook
yeah right remember when facebook was
just like a cool kids thing
and like the parents their parents
didn't get it my parents still didn't
they still think it that way yeah
because it was really funny because i
remember
one day um because i you know i've you
know we are all grown up on the internet
and especially
i've been doing youtube and social media
for like a long time
one day my mum phones me up um and this
this was
this was when i had stopped using
facebook by this point i'd like most of
my online life has gone to twitter
because that's my job and everything
um but my parents had just started
really getting into facebook and you
know
being being that being that parents who
you know tag tag you in everything
comment on people's photos you know
properly involved yeah yeah
and i remember she phones me up one day
and she goes
uh gant um someone left a mean comment
on one of my photos what do i do i'm
just like
what what do you mean mom what what do
you mean what do you do and she's like
i i don't know what to do it makes me
feel sad
i kind of want to reply and i'm just
like mom
do not do not do this do not reply right
now
do not get involved that's the one thing
you should not do
it was just funny because um because
like years ago she was like
she's like you know just just just
ignore all the mean comments online and
just don't worry about it as you know as
the parents do because you know
as someone as as a parent watching a kid
do
social media and do youtube you just
don't get it you see comments you're
just like
these comments don't mean anything right
yeah yeah but it was funny seeing
seeing my parents who had never been
into social media go through the same
cycle that we had to go
we had to go through being like what
what is a mean comment why are people
commenting mean things on me this
doesn't make sense you know what
i'm gonna reply i'm going to give the
trolls everything they want
at least your mom wasn't like do you
know the number to the cyber police
i need to report a crime